Hey traders, it's Mike Carr, and in this
video I'll be talking about the order
flow exhaustion entry model that's
quietly replacing everything else. You
know, nobody else is talking about it.
I'm the only one that's talking about
it. I'm sure you in a few months you're
going to start to see a a load of
followers posting videos as if they've
invented fire. But,
once traders see this and start using
it, I find that other that they've been
replacing it with their existing methods
of trading because of the simplicity.
You know, I've been showing you charts
for the last several weeks in E-minis,
in bonds, in euro currencies, and people
say, "Oh, you know what? You're just
cherry-picking your charts." You know,
like like this was on Friday
in the ultra bonds, right? We had that
nice sell-off. But, you know, the same
entry model that I use in S&Ps, in
bonds, ultra bonds, euro currency, work
just about every market. Okay? Now, of
course, you know, every market has
different volatility,
you know, and depending on the chart
type that you're using. I like to keep
it simple. Keep it
the same type of chart, you know, a
time-based a 1-minute chart. You could
use a 30-second chart. You could use
range charts.
You know, it doesn't matter. You know,
once you start applying this
entry model, you know, you're going to
see trades just really jumping out at
you. And and someone had asked me,
"Okay, you know, that's all well and
good, but I don't trade on a four-range
chart in in bonds or ultra bonds. You
know, I trade crude oil." Okay.
You know, what chart you trading? You
trade a time-based chart, a 1-minute
chart? Okay, let's pull up
crude on a 1-minute chart. And I'm using
my same
template, right? This is my
Order Flows Trader. I'm just using my
Order Flows Trader eight exhaustion
template. I'll put it on the crude here,
and well, this is ultra bonds, but I'll
switch over to a crude oil chart.
Okay.
And let's take a look at at it. Okay?
Now, these are the same settings whether
it is ultra bonds, E-minis, crude oil.
Okay, let's let's just uh take a look. I
can see there were some shorts from
earlier. Okay, right here.
It would be a little bit hard to see.
Now, granted, this is uh 3:20 in the
afternoon on Friday. There's a nice
bullish signal, and it went from, you
know, whatever this was, 96.20.
You know, rallied a buck in the last uh
hour of trading. You got a bearish
signal here right before the futures
closed, but, you know, I'm you're
probably not going to take that. But, uh
let's take a look at, you know, some of
the other signals on this day here.
Let's sort of scrunch it up so we get a
little bit more information. Okay,
here's a short signal right here. You
can see the
signal came here, sold off, went back up
to the level, and sold off some more.
Okay.
Um how about the little bit pre-
previous? Got another signal came in
right here.
Okay. This is a nice little trade here.
Again, this is crude, doesn't look like
much. We're talking a move from 60,
you know, down
really quick, within a few minutes, down
to uh 20. That's a 40-cent move. Even
got down to uh just about 96.00. Okay.
Now, here's a trade that whoops. Here's
a trade that doesn't look like it
worked. Yeah, this one would have uh
started to work, but then it just
stopped you out, this one right here in
the middle. Okay. You know, fine. You
know, there's going to be some trades
that stop you out. Uh
whoops.
>> [sighs]
>> Uh marking tool.
Um
let's see. Oh, look at this, you know.
This was a beautiful trade right here.
Here was couple shorts
that came in
right here,
right here. I mean, you just you're
getting short here, 97 bucks.
You know, this is
these are the trades that you love as a
trader, where it drops,
you know, 97
down to 96, down to 95. Okay, actually
got came down, made new lows. Um prior
to this trade here, you had this nice
little sell-off right here.
Okay, you know, just sort of based on
here before it came back up. And you got
your next sell signal right there.
Okay?
Um
okay, here's a
Here you can just see these little
signals here.
This is a buy. This is a sell. Here's
your buy. Here's your sell.
Okay, this is a small buy.
Sell, it just sort of went sideways.
What else we got here?
Okay.
Here's a little long. This was about 25
cents.
Um um um
okay.
Here it's a little hard to see, but you
had one winner, one loser.
This one would have stopped you out,
this first one right here.
This one stopped you out. It just sort
of went up and then came back down,
stopped you out. But then, look at this,
it came right back with this monster
move off the low of the day here. It's a
little hard to see. This green line
right here, this little
uh
up pyramid, up triangle. Right? And
you're talking to move from 96.20
just all the way up to 97.20 within uh
from about 8:15 to about 8:35. Okay, so
about 20 minutes. It's a nice move.
Um so you know, I mean that that's crude
oil, right? And you know, I get a lot of
messages, "Well, you know, I don't trade
crude. I don't trade this. I trade this.
Uh micro gold, you know."
Someone says, "How about micro gold? How
does it look on micro gold?" Well, let's
take a look. Again, this is the same
um 1-minute chart with the exact same
settings.
You know, and again, you know, late in
the day you had a nice little short
right here.
You know,
you know, in the last 15 minutes traded
had a had a long. So, you had But again,
you know, you're not going to be on
Friday afternoon at uh 3:30 taking
trades. Um you know, there's a nice long
here. You would say, "What about this
one? This one failed." Well, no, it
didn't because the next bar didn't go
higher than the high of the entry bar.
Okay? Um let's take a look. That's Is
there any other trades on this day? I'm
sure there There's got to be.
Um
Here's a
Oops, where am I here? Draw this line.
Okay, so here's a long entry, right? You
see there,
there, there, but none of these trades
kick off because
you know, part of the entry model is
letting the next bar or two trade higher
than the bar with the entry signal. So,
even though you've got your signal right
here, right? Your entry is just going to
be right above the high of this bar.
Just as here, it's going to be right
above the high. Here, right above the
high. And we don't go any higher in
either of these two bars,
right? Here and here. So, there's no
trade. Okay, even though you have your
exhaustion print, your exhaustion print,
your exhaustion print. That's just one
part of it.
Okay.
Uh
let's see what else we got here.
Anything?
Bueller? Bueller?
Okay, there's a couple of shorts right
here.
Here,
here. Next bar trades down. Docking
4521, gets down. Next bar literally goes
from
21 down to 18, trades about trades
around 18 a few times, you know, but
mostly 19s. So,
couple of boxes in here again. Here's
your short. You spend a lot of time down
here, does rally back up before going
down, down, down,
down to about 16. Okay.
And what else we got?
Okay, this one we had one
Here's your signal, but again, we don't
trade below here in the next two bars,
so no trade.
This one, okay, yeah.
Would've got your short, but stopped
out. So, this is a trade you would've
have taken. And then obviously this was
the one where, you know, we started
selling down and went lower.
Okay.
Um
you know, and then here it's only like
what, 10:00 right now. This is 10:05 in
the morning.
Surely there's got to be something else.
Okay.
Well, there's a couple signals here.
These two.
You know, when you're looking at the
entry signal here and here, so this one
would have got you in. It sort of went
sideways.
Maybe it would have stopped you out,
maybe you would have got a small profit.
This one
you know, similar. You just
barely got you in. So, this one would
have been a
trade you got into and again stopped
out. So, you know, stop.
Stopped. Stopped. Okay. You know, but
you got to realize this is a market
that's a bit more volatile than some of
these other markets.
And as a result, you know, you're going
to get
stopped out a little bit more just
simply because there's more volatility.
So, like this one here, right? You get
short. And again, it depends on what
your your targets are. Even though these
these moves look small, you're talking a
move from 26 down to, you know, 23, $3
move. This was a little move that
started up at 24, got up to 28. So, it's
you know, $4 move.
You know, it depends on what your
targets are. You know, this is a nice
trade. You're getting short from here
around 31.
You know, it goes from 31 all the way
down to down to 21. That's a $10 move.
So, you know, even though you're getting
stopped out on a couple of these little
trades,
they
there's still the capacity for some
big much bigger trades, you know.
Down here. All right, let me look at
these longs from, you know, down here.
There's There's this this long
is a nice trade. Okay.
And you know, that's just on Friday. You
know, if if to go back,
you know, some other days, you know,
there'd
also be some nice trades. You know,
there's a nice long.
This is
Thursday, there's a long here, there's a
short here, there's another short here.
And again, it depends on
what your target is. If you're taking
this, well, this short wouldn't got you
in, but if you're taking this short
here, right from
you know, whatever that is, 43 45 43, it
gets down to 40, comes back up, even
gets down to 36 before it goes back up.
You know, what is your target?
Right? Are you trying to get $10? So, if
you're getting short at 43, your
target's down here. When you you're
looking at, you know, six
seven points in the money.
Again, you know, it depends on your
target. Now, this
What was this? This was gold MGC.
Um you know, someone said, you know,
they
they're more interested in
mini Russell, RTY. Okay, let's take a
look here.
Mini Russell.
Why I got no This is weird. That's what
I don't like about Ninja Trader
sometimes. My 1-minute chart doesn't
work.
But the 60-second chart works just fine.
I mean, 60 seconds is still 1 minute. Um
let's just scroll through here.
Okay.
And this is a small one right ahead of
the cash close, 2:30.
I see
Here's a long that didn't necessarily
This one started going up, came right
back down, that would have stopped you
out.
But again, you know, I I I want to show
you guys in different markets. I mean,
I mean, here it's from the high of the
day, get this bearish signal.
Okay, you can see you got some bullish
signals here. There was a bearish one
here. This one would have stopped you
out.
So, you got a bullish signal here, so it
went from here up to here.
Get short here. This one stops you out,
but then you got a nice short signal
here.
You know, and then you're talking a move
from 81
down into the 70s, 76 area, right in
here.
You know, and again, you know, this was
Friday ahead of ahead of the holiday.
You know, here's a
Let's
uh scroll back a little bit more. You
know, there's
you got some shorts here, you can see.
You know, short, short. Here's a long,
right? You got this move where it just
sort of puked out.
Okay, here's a nice short. See this one
right here.
You know, obviously on these markets
that are more volatile, like RTY
compared to E-minis, you're seeing a lot
more signals, right? I mean, on Friday
there was just a handful of signals in
the S&P's.
Um and you can see these signals in
here. I can go through a lot some of
these, but um
you know, some
nice winners, some you know, some
losers.
Uh let's go back
the previous day. Um Thursday. You know,
here's a nice trade.
You got There's a couple of nice trades,
you know.
Especially if you're on a trend day, so
this one would have stopped you out cuz
you got short, came back up here. This
one you would be no trade, but this was
a beautiful trade, right? If you took
this one, right? I mean, people say,
"Well, I got stopped out here. This This
is This is the central miles sucks."
You know, you got one, two, three
opportunities. The second one is not
even a trade, but this third one, right?
You're getting short way up here.
trades all the way down to
40.
Then you get a bullish signal here, and
it trades back up from back up from 40,
back up to 50. I mean, it quite
literally does this to you for you. Um
You know, I mean you you you got to
realize when you're trading markets that
move
faster, quicker, you're going to get
maybe opportunities for a little bit
more stop outs.
This one wouldn't even happen. It
wouldn't even like that. Your signal
there, right? It doesn't go any lower.
This one does, you know, and again, it's
a move from 54
down into the 40s. The high 40s, 47, 48.
Okay? This is 48 right here.
You know,
I'm going
12.
This one would have stopped you
out.
Some small ones here. So, this is a
trade here, starts to go up a little
bit, comes back, this bullish one.
This is interesting. Okay?
Let me Let me expand this up a little
bit here and just sort of talk about it
cuz this is part of the entry model that
you got to understand. So,
Okay, this trade here, right? You're
getting long here, right? When you break
out above that high, and it starts to go
up.
Right? And again, it's a decent move.
It's it's about
two or three points.
And again, it depends on what you're
using as your target. I like to be
optimistic and try and capture as much
as you can. But then here, this one,
okay? This is when you'd get long. And
look at this, this next bar came down,
traded below your entry signal, but the
next bar got you in. That's why I say
you I give it two bars to work out.
And then, you know, you're getting long
from about 20.
And what happens? It goes from 20.
I mean, this is a beautiful one. It It
shoots up here a little bit later when,
you know, I believe there was some talks
of peace happening
with Iran.
But from 20 all the way up to 30,
eventually it up, It all the way up to
40s.
Okay, I mean, you did have a bearish
signal here, but
you know, so if you're long from 20, you
know, getting out at 30, that's a great
trade in the Russell.
See, there was a bearish signal here
from earlier overhead.
All right, so this is a nice bearish
signal here. You can just see how it how
it worked
right here, right? Sideways, sideways,
and then it drops back down to 18.
So, again, you're you're looking at a
move from around 25
down to, you know, this is 20 here.
You know,
this yellow line is our opening price,
which is going to act as a magnet.
Okay?
So, you know, that's the beauty of the
order flow exhaustion entry model
because it it really
clues you in as to what's about to
happen, right? You can forget about your
your indicators, your stochastics, your
bands, your moving averages, whatever.
Um
you know, lines drawn from stuff that
probably doesn't have much relevance.
You know, what you're looking at the
order flow, especially specifically with
exhaustion prints, is what's happening
right now in the markets.
Okay?
Volume is thinning. No new money is
coming in to push the move further.
That level's going to hold,
right? And then what happens? You have
silence from those aggressive traders.
They're not interested in moving the
market further. And then what happens?
The natural you know, once you remove
that aggression from the market, the
market's just going to naturally move
back
in the opposite direction.
Okay? Now, you know, I again, I I've
traded exhaustion for a long time, and
it comes in many
um different names, shapes, and forms,
but really the key point is when the
last buyer has bought or when the last
seller has sold, and only the footprint
chart allows you to see that. You cannot
see that exhaustion on a candlestick
chart on a bar chart. You need to be
looking at the volume. You know, I
created the Order Flows Trader software
to help me see things in the order flow
that other people aren't looking at. An
exhaustion print is is, you know, one of
the foundation
forms of analysis in order flow.
Okay? Because it is telling you what's
taking place in the market and what you
need to focus on.
So,
thanks for watching this video. You
know, I really do hope that you
one day start using a footprint chart if
you're not already because I do believe
it really just opens up your eyes as to
what's happening in the market. But,
it's not just about having an exhaustion
print in the market, right? I mean, you
know, here's here's some more
trades to take. You know, okay, you get
stopped out, stopped out, then boom, you
get the nice trade that gets it all back
in one fell swoop. You know, it's not
just about having an exhaustion print
like you have here.
The entry model, you have to let the
market start trading up if it's a
bullish signal. If it's staying below
this level, there's no trade.
Okay? So, again, you know, thanks for
watching this video, guys. I'll catch
you on my next video. Take care.